con retraso sobre el horario inicial
previsto partió la primera jornada del
nuevo presidente de chile gabriel en la
moneda al saludo militar protocolar
siguió una ceremonia de encuentro con
los pueblos originarios recordemos que
en chile existen 10 pueblos originarios
aunque el mayoritario más conocido en el
que se auto reconoce un 10 por ciento de
la población es el pueblo mapuche en
esta ceremonia participaron sabios
sabios representantes ancestrales y
miembros de esta comunidad de lo que fue
una serie de prerrogativas y también
intercambios para desear un nuevo buen
comienzo a este nuevo ciclo que parte en
el país y que estará marcado por un
trabajo intercultural se dijo un 6 desde
la moneda en el que se incidió en que
chile va a ser ahora reconocido como un
territorio plurinacional en esta
ceremonia participó tanto el presidente
de había el boliche como la primera dama
irina cara manos que después se
trasladaron a la catedral de santiago
para participar de una ceremonia
ecuménica en la que también se realizó
una oración por el nuevo gobierno y por
el pueblo de chile mañana el presidente
de boliche y la primera dama karamanos
se desplazarán a uno barrios más
desfavorecidos de santiago la pintana
donde tendrán una actividad de
intercambio con la comunidad estas son
las actividades que marcan por tanto el
primer fin de semana del nuevo gobierno
de chile